this show is brought to you by
meundies go to meundies.com and shipping
is always free in the US and Canada and
you can save up to $8 a pair with the
meandi subscription plan get the
subscription or a single pair and get
20% off of your first order when you go
to meundies.com joeey that's
meundies.com
jooy show is also brought to you by Blue
Apron Blue Apron sends Gourmet recipes
and all the fresh ingredients you need
to make them right to your door our
listeners get their first two meals for
free just go to blueapron.com Joey and
start cooking incredible meals at home
with blue apron that's blueapron.com
Joey and the show is brought to you by
on it.com go to on it.com and use code
word church to get 10% off all of the
great optimization products like Alpha
Brain and new mood what's up gentlemen
hey we were talking about how uh like I
look at you sometime I go yeah I could
tell he lived in New York and you like
New York did you start there yes started
in New York I worked at uh Caroline's
comedy club sweeping the floors
answering the phones just first job at a
college just as a [__] job to just get
through and pay the bills and uh I
watched everybody I saw Chappelle
everybody everybody that was on SNL
Margaret show would come in and you know
everybody that was coming into New York
City was headlining Carolines I saw
everybody and I just thought that looks
like [__] fun so that's how I got
into it I like four months later I tried
to stand up New York and then after as
soon as I did it the first time I said
I'm doing that the rest of my
life that's [__] it just hooks you
yeah it just hooks you it's just like a
it's like a silent addiction yeah that
you don't really even
feel and you're like wait a second I
like doing this and then they tell you
about the life that you're going about
to go into that's the scariest when they
tell you about the life you're about to
go into well do you really know what
happens you're like [__] yeah you go on
the road you bang women and you're like
no
no and then you're like you know what
I'm still going to go for it once you
ask and ask and ask yeah cuz that's what
I did I worked at a comedy club and I
just asked the headliner in the feature
in the MC asked him you know for 8 weeks
I was such a [__] I would not get on
stage I would just keep asking every new
Tuesday I would become friends with them
or bring them weed and what's it like
and you know they would tell me well you
know it's kind of rough and we you know
some nights sleep in our car and you
know at first you're like [__] it I can
do it you know what I'm saying [__] the
car well some night you got a [__] in
you know it was just crazy what they
would tell me you know so how many
people working at comedy clubs do you
think want to be comedians like the door
guys servers cuz I never look at those
people and think oh those are the next
Comics I just figured it was a job
people got for a job but it seems like
it's a lot of comics I think it's like
7030 70 are there to work and then 30% I
think end up becoming a trans or wanting
to do it or are there to be Comics like
you go to La Hoya it's like the whole
staff is Comics but you go to like you
know anywhere else in the country like
an improv I think like the door guy
sometimes the sound guy they want to do
stand up but most of the waitresses
they're just there to pay their bills I
don't know that's what I think but we
were doing a podcast a few weeks ago and
I actually went home I told how I kind
of got into it and I went home and
really thought about it and I went and I
tried to find that movie and I couldn't
find it a punchline with Sally Struthers
and Tom Hanks like I always knew I
wanted to do it but once I saw that
movie that pushed me over yeah I made
some calls and I stalled for a while
then I saw a standup class in the paper
and but it was so weird how in Colorado
you
have if you live in the Denver Boulder
area listen the truth is of the matter
I'm telling you this is honest there's
four cold weeks a year the two weeks
before the the new year and the first
two weeks of January after that you're
pretty much done those are the only two
weeks four weeks that we would have to
cancel work as roofers when I estimated
I would estimate but the cruise couldn't
work there was either snow or it was
windy or it was icy or something like
that and I would stay home and rent
movies and that was one of the movies
thank God for that [__] snowstorm you
know what I'm saying and I watched that
movie and it just blew my mind like I
had never my mom had a bar but I had
never dreamt of having a locker at a
comedy club right right yeah did you did
you pick that movie for a reason or did
you just were like at a video store and
I was a video store I was at a video
store looking for
standup shows and I saw that movie about
standup with Tom Hanks I like Tom Hanks
I picked it up and it blew me away I
mean Damon Waynes is in it Angel Salazar
is in it yeah s Sally what's her name
Sally Field Sally Fields is in it it's
just a great flick you know the comedy
club owner is so cheesy in that yeah you
know it's your night baby you know what
I'm saying remember me 10% like he was
trying to be manag it like that oh just
it just really
uh Sparks your curiosity like [__]
work [__] insurance insurance is for
[__] [__] I pulled out my own tooth
last month and [__] I don't need no
[__]
dentist oh my God just thinking about it
gives me an gives me an ult where was
your first time when did you get up 1991
at the Denver Comedy Works on a Tuesday
open mic night wow I mean what better
Club than that that's a what was going
on Steve bur no idea I read Judy cter
workbook and I had done the [__]
three weeks at at the
class did you learn anything from the
class confidence yeah the guy pulled me
aside and said you know what man if you
you could do this m he was a long island
guy
and no no no no it he was part of an
improv
troop uh Harms Jeff harms that was this
Comics name and he was part of an intert
with Matt Woods Matt Barry Matt Barry is
huge in Hollywood today if you IMDb Matt
Barry Matt Barry's been here for 20
years just ripping people's heads off as
a showrunner executive producer you know
he's been on TV with 20 different
[__] shows right but those guys were
the rumors the rumors were when I was
coming up that they had written the act
for Roseanne the one that she brought
out here right Denver has always been a
den for great writers mhm they just they
Dr whatever I don't know what the [__]
but one thing for sure like uh Roger
Rittenhouse and Steve mcru and all those
guys used to live together Rick Karns
who is now a huge writer for uh uh Ron
White and those guys you know I mean he
how many shows has he been on he's been
on a bunch but nothing it wasn't like a
a lot of I I don't think they maybe put
standup stuff on there because I didn't
see that on his IM no no no no no no no
no I'm talking about TV shows that he's
executive produced and showrun Matt
Barry had like 19 shows M like I've been
through the I walked through the one of
the Lots one day and saw his name
painted on one of the things I was like
God damn when they paint your own
parking spot like close to the door
like I'm look I got a weird actor for
him so I'll look for another it's okay
it's just it's just so that was the
those guys were the guys that I watched
and said all right yeah but it was weird
I got on stage I had a day job like I
left there floating on ice but then by
the time I got to the car I said it's a
pipe dream yeah you know who the [__] am
I I'm a [__] piece of [__] [__]
ese roofs I still blow I can't do that
[__] exceptional people do that [__]
yeah then I started reading books by
that time I knew Richard briy lit
himself on fire so I had half a chance
you know once somebody lights themselves
on fireable of that I could do it I
could he lived you know uh you know just
these comics when I was growing up you
know Freddy Prince killed himself yeah
Freddy Prince was [__]
hugely it's hard to sell FY Freddy
Prince unless you live through it like
Freddy Prince was a regular guy he was
on Chico and the Man and it was over it
was overly and he used to walk around
that comedy store and shoot guns in the
back of the comedy store and [__] and
one day he couldn't take it he shot
himself and that was the end he had to
show after s and son so everybody
watched it but the beauty about this kid
he was Puerto Rican and Johnny Carson
was putting him on the panel and the air
was he was going to replace Johnny
Carson I mean he was just a personable
guy if you listen to one of his standup
routines today you're like guys go [__]
yourselves this guy's terrible that's
how that's how see if you can find an
old standup routine of Freddy Prince
just see you'll die I I bought a CD once
I was all excited I bought it like at a
at like one those places in Texas I was
on the road I had like a 4-Hour drive
I'm like [__] Freddy Prince yeah this
guy was my hero growing up I threw it oh
my God oh my God I almost went off a
[__] cliff can I tell you I I
introduced Martin Lawrence uh at the
store maybe like a few months ago and I
thought [__] hey Martin Lawrence holy
[__] CU I used to work at a video store
in college where we would deliver the
videos to your dorm room so I lived it
was called Video 101 in Kent State so so
I watch I I and I would get all the
movie posters so I had this Martin
Lawrence you so crazy poster and I
watched the video all the time and I
might I must have watched that thing a
hundred times in college I [__] loved
it and then I brought him up and I was
like [__] I should go back and watch
that now I've been seen it forever
probably since I was in college and I I
wasn't even thinking of doing stand up
that put in watch I was like this is the
[__] oh my God what was I you're like
what was I thinking god herey let's see
what this guy's got 1970 whatever 74
thank you uh I'm not originally from La
I Come From New York I'm one of the uh
New York Puerto Ricans and well not
really not completely cuz uh my father's
Hungarian so I'm a
hungan that's why I I know I don't look
it right I got light skinn straight hair
that's from my father from my Puerto
Rican mother I got my nose and my
mustache I grew up in New York in a
neighbor
uh Washington Heights it's not really a
ghetto it's a ghetto suburb right slums
with trees right even the Birds are
junkies birds don't know how to fly they
just fall out of trees and bother
people tweet tweet sucker give me a
quarter cockroaches wear sneakers and
dungar cockroaches are strong you can't
kill them you ever noticed you step on
them you hear them snap soon as you lift
your foot they run like
H that's cuz they know we believe the
snap means they're dead so they're going
chump and they're
gone not bad though the manager of the
apartment building name is Mr Riva
Puerto Rican guy that's what's his name
dead you know that fredd Prince J yeah
yeah all right you put it together I
didn't know that's he looks like the
dude from uh Scarface or was he in
Scarface Fredy no he was dead by
that that's crazy he looks like he looks
like his friend doesn't he or maybe I'm
thinking of a different movie it's crazy
cuz the night I still remember the night
he shot himself I was by the high school
I still wasn't in high school I was
still in [__] grammar school and it
was freezing out it was one of those
nights I made a mistake Jack and a
certain time in those days the buses
went out of service so if you cut
yourself up there at 11:05 like you you
were dead you know you were [__]
freezing yeah and uh I walked home I'll
never forget I cut through the cemetery
and I had to take a [__] and I'm like
Jesus Christ this could only happen to
me I eat like bad pizza or something
like that and the kid I'm with I'm like
walk ahead of me but stay close cuz the
rumor was there was devil worshipers in
the cemetery at night so I like just
pulled my pants halfway down and just
you know I was very Catholic at the time
I was very respectful I look for a grave
that was very old like that even his
family wasn't around you and they had
them they had Graves there from 1892 and
[__] so I like it [__] here and these
people dead you know even the cousins
are dead and I took a [__] and when I
pulled my pants on I left my pants on
and I peed in the p i don't forget this
I peed it in the pants and it was so
cold out that the pants froze oh [__]
and I had to walk home like with
shingles piss shingles that were falling
off my little [__] pants
like that's my memory of Freddy Prince
man taking a [__] in a in a cemetery in
a cemetery on a [__] cold January
night or something why did he pee your
pants it was just by accident no cuz I
left it was so cold I left the pants and
kiss the devil worshippers came I only
[__] but I left my dick in the pants so
I'm looking around for devil worshippers
not knowing that I'm peeing as when you
[__] you automatically pee right or
wrong I don't know nobody just shits and
Just sh never shot outside before
so that's [__] crazy listen man
you're right though it is a double
whammy you can't do one without the
other yeah think about like you can just
pee that's fine but when it's a deuce
you're getting the kitten koodle yeah
you do the whole and you pee and then
you flush and then you pee and [__]
again you know when I'm there it's like
three or four little flushes and lookies
and the whole thing but you pee in
between all those you're like how was I
holding all this
pee how the [__] was I holding all this
pee you have a pee for like 10 minutes
and you're like where is this [__]
coming from yeah oh that's the that's my
favorite part of waking up in the
morning it's like the those long ass
peas and
and what you [__] both is get
older when you got to get up three times
a night like you got to stop drinking on
a two hour like on a two night two you
know those two show nights yeah you got
to step you got to do the second show
like dehydrating like a year be AF with
Africans chasing you and [__] like
because if not once you turn 50 you'll
be up three times peeing and I didn't
get it for a long time I get like I get
like a venty coffee at like midnight
yeah I'd be peeing till 6:00 in the
[__] morning every hour on the hour
you're like [__] you got to take the
sleep at and your mask off and [__]
walk and pee and come back and put it
on oh when you get older guys it it
really is a nightmare the [__] pee
thing becomes a [__] nightmare yeah
at like four how old are you now 42 not
41 yeah 48 you start peeing like a
[__] you're like I got to watch
my water intake then you go to the
doctor and get blood and they're like
you know you're a little dehydrated sure
I'm [__] dehydrated I can't drink
nothing I want to sleep oh you can't dog
when I leave my house in Studio City in
the morning right here whatever the [__]
I live right here by the time I get the
wax list I got to pee like by the time I
get the 101 I get off that Kanga exit
I'm looking for a bathroom sometimes you
find one sometimes you don't you do what
you need to do you go behind a 7-Eleven
I swear to God I got to pee all the
[__] time well I used to do that in
Boston like pee in like on the street
but I don't do I'm always too scared to
do it out here well it's the body
language you could just stand there make
believe you talking on the phone be
peeing nobody would know what do you do
with the growing puddle by your feet you
spit in between two cars and make
believe like one of the cars is yours
you just touch the paint like you're in
love with it like oh my God look at this
paint job it's like a magician people
looking at you pet in the car they don't
see you peeing I do it all the time man
I pee at rals I have to I'm old bro I
don't have time to go in and pee I'll
just open the door and make believe I'm
on the cell phone I'm looking for
something and the whole time the the
[__] drive from from the house to the
airport oh once I park in terminal 4 for
American Airlines I don't even wait
right there as I'm pulling the luggage
out my dick's out I'm just making
believe I'm peeing out my sneakers I
don't care I don't really at this point
that little drive from the house to the
airport it's not a little drive but you
guys know what I'm saying what do you do
on Long flights cuz I always pick I get
up in pee Oh I'm a big I even when I was
bigger I always pick the window cuz I
hated getting up on that [__] no I get I
get I listen I didn't know this for
years that you have to have water with
the whole
flight did you know that I didn't know
this I just saw this about years H the
whole flight you got to have water next
to you you have to be drinking I forget
what to do 4 ounces every [__] hour
it's something crazy on a plane because
there's some type of radiation I don't
know it I can't break it down for the
people at home I'm just telling you that
once I started drinking water on a plane
everything changed like soda is not
healthy on a plane alcohol is even worse
they say you know you know for 20 years
I did everything on a B Store to blow on
a plane you know I smoked pot one time
doing in ' 84 I smoked dope on a plane
with a soldier really that I just come
back from some country wasn't like a
fighter or something he just we took a
flight from San Francisco together he's
like man I let go for a reefer I go dog
I got a bowl right in my [__] pocket
I lighter in some weed went to the back
of the plane and started smoking weed
like animals because in those days you
could yeah you could smoke cigarettes
but that's when I get on a plane I see
that metal ashtray I'm like oh this
[__] plane's going down
I haven't been on a plane forever this
yeah USA always got people smoking on
that they got the air things for lung
people who had cancer and got on the
planes US Air those [__] planes are
ratty dog how they still up there not
going down is beyond me every time I get
a call to go to Philly I you only got to
take USA twice a year yeah Philly and
some other [__] place that's it I
think I'm not even going to Philly that
route no more yeah I'm just going to
going to LA J jka whatever the [__] it
is JK whatever what is it can JFK JFK
jka whatever the [__] it is I rent the
car and drive to Philly those us
airplanes they're going to start going
down any [__] Daya is it like one of
the propeller ones I don't even know
what the [__] it is dog I know that you
hear animals and [__] I know that
American Airlines bought them and they
ain't [__] they ain't they ain't
sparking no every time you take off on
the US airflight the thing [__]
rattles like the the brothers [__]
took that air up and so it rattles man
it's like Soul Plane it really [__]
rattles I'm not trying to be cute or
funny here I'm waiting for USA to start
dropping out of the [__] Sky every
time I watch that's another thing 6:30 I
don't want nobody bother me cuz that's
my world news tonight for years I had
Dian s they broke my heart they [__]
had got rid of her cuz she started
getting liing spots so
they they they replaced him with
whatever his name is who I like he's
very good but I always watch and every
night lately the last [__] uh couple
months three nights a week they always
talk about a flight problem and I'm
sitting there pulling for USA it's got
to be USA and then they throw you off at
like America and the Southwest or some
[__] I can't believe people get like in
fights on planes didn't it just happen a
couple times recently people getting
like huge and they have to they have to
divert something I think in the last
week do they do not [__] around on
flights no
more I tell you what I told you Jody
fdick got drunk with four five dudes in
San Francisco they got on the plane one
of them grabbed her [__] she broke his
nose what they arrested everybody they
arrested the five dudes and Jodi fdick
everybody got yanked off the plane in
[__] handcuffs they don't [__] around
on planes yeah I had a problem on a
plane once twice I had a problem on that
plane when that plane landed the cops
were there [__] waiting they come
right on the plane and they sit next to
you and they go we got to take care of
something and they talk to you they
don't [__] around at all is zero
tolerance Ralphie May is not a lot on
United for kicking the counter cuz he
missed his fight like that 55 minute
window thing yeah like they make you
they should have given him a medal cuz I
can't see him getting his foot above
anything that he kicked the CLE low you
know what I'm saying it was like an
inched thing he just kicked it like and
he it wasn't even like something
malicious and nothing yeah he just like
going [__] right you know what am I
going to tell the club like one of those
no sudden two cops came and squaded him
out and he's not allowed in the United
terminal that's crazy if they don't dog
they do not play that's why at airports
I I I put my iPod I don't even listen to
people I don't want to talk to nobody
cuz what happens if you snap the next
thing you know you're in a [__]
rushian jail with watching Midnight
Express you seen Midnight Express yeah I
get on a plane I'm in the exit row pull
the Hat down against the window I'm out
like a light wake me if you need a hero
that's it I'm done every flight every
flight I fall fall asleep I don't know
what it does but the minute we go up in
the air I guess maybe the lack of oxygen
I just I'm out God bless you I always
sleep I I wish I could [__] pass out
planes like the old days do you have to
take a sleeping pill or you just are you
just out I'm just out he's one of those
dudes I'm not like Mr T where I need to
drink the they Spike the milk and I'm
[__] no I'm just I get against the
window and sometimes even they they're
like yeah you got an upgrade to the
first class I'm like I don't I don't
need it I'm going to be asleep here in 2
minutes I feel maybe it's even like
conditioned where I get on the plane I
feel like oh I can sleep now that's
crazy I maybe it's a skinny thing I
always used to be jealous of the girls
who could lay down on their on their
trade table and fall asleep I maybe it
was just when I was big I couldn't like
get comfortable in the seat it's tough
on what seat in any airplane SE oh my
god when I was at my biggest I was on a
virgin plane and and like the like I
kept going over the seat rest and it's
uncomfortable and then you're
uncomfortable it's tough being big on a
plane it's it's like it's obviously
tough for everyone around you but it's
like it's that's one of the worst things
about being big is getting on a plane
like that's why I would I always sat in
the window for other people so they
wouldn't get a so I wouldn't have to
jump no well it's not even me being
sweet it's me it's me being embarrassed
compliment like I you're a sweet young
man he's AET I'm very sweet but I don't
want to I don't want to step like I
would be embarrassed to step over
something like I can't make like you
know when when you're a kid and you're
jumping over like fences or whatever
I've never once jumped over anything I
don't like I I would always trip on that
stuff if I have like the shortest legs
in the world I can't reach over anybody
so I just sit in the corner and I just I
don't I would never get up on a plane
what a sweet lonely young man you are
I'm sorry I never jumped the fence
either every time I jump the fence I got
caught too I think I ripped my hand I
was not a good fence jump you got to
have a different type of [__] uh and
I was thin and I couldn't jump a fence I
didn't do a my first pull-up I was like
[__] 20 I just had no strength in my
arms I had to lift weights and do a
th000 [__] push-ups I couldn't do a
pull-up I never got the patch from the
Pres President's Fitness [__] I had a
cond the gym teacher you know what I'm
saying give him like a fan and bring him
a hot dog and [__] to get a [__]
patch from the president I could through
push-up sit up squats high jump long
jump I could through everything I just
couldn't something about my hands what
is it about it when you're young that
you can do like a thousand push-ups as a
little kid but then when you get older
like why don't your arms like stay as
just as strong like little kids can do
like hundreds of push-ups what am I Nick
at KN you got to [__] you know what I'm
saying I I don't know why you're you
might be Nick night my [__] wife
drops my daughter off at 8:30 in the
morning she runs around till 5:45 my
wife picks her up for the Valentine Day
she sent me the videos it was basically
her running around for an hour and a
half that's eight hours nine hours of
[__] running around then they get
home and they put heels on and dresses
and they [__] make cakes and you know
you got to play games with them the
[__] game you gave with the
lightbrite last night I'm over there
putting [__] off on it and [__] and
building it with it you know and never
ends the energy is [__] endless who
knows listen man I grew up in a time
when you left your house at 8:00 in the
morning you didn't go back in for dinner
homework and then you ran around till 10
when I first came from Cuba there was so
much trust on the streets that kids you
had 8 20 you had 12 kids on the [__]
street that knew each other from the
ages of 6 to 12 everybody played
together everybody played together you
played everything stick ball two-and
touch football okay let's go underne
then you come back let's go look at the
dead body over on Chandler that just got
stabbed then you go look at him that's a
mile walk it's a [__] Mile Walk That
You Did In 3 Minutes
flat you know and you weren't tired
after it nothing I used to walk to two
guys and I was a kid I lived on 38 two
guys two guys was on [__] 15th Street
what's two guys two guys is like this
[__] or yeah yeah Walmart in 1970s
before TVs whatever and me and these
guys used to walk it but it was one of
those Hills that it was like this but
for 20 minutes you can't do that today
nobody could do that today no can do
that we'd do that [__] twice a day we'd
walk to two guys you know like you went
and bought a basketball and or you went
and bought a bike tire and the bike the
tube didn't work how do you think you
got back there you took a cab or you
think they had Uber you walked back but
your bike like a half a [__] Momo
like a soldier then you had to fix it
there bring it back then you realize you
forgot the pin for the basketball got to
ride the bike back over there you know
that was you did that three four [__]
I grew up in the second hilliest city in
the country did you know that North
Bergen New Jersey is the second hilliest
Hill in the country it's right over the
Lincoln Tunnel yeah right when you get
off the route three that's North Bergen
second most hilliest in San Francisco
you don't know what I went through as a
kid that's why I'll never die yeah cuz I
got a heart of a [__] tank you know
what I'm saying you how many times I
walked up that hill for [__] Iced
Teas and Chinese rice and you know you
know you how many [__] ideas in the
winter how many time you had to walk in
for breakfast to go to the high school
then if you wanted to go out and get
Sicky Dicky sucky you had to [__]
walk it again at night dog you know and
don't talk to him about taking a [__] in
the graveyard you don't want to
know cuz there's no pisser I still you
got to piss your pants I still remember
it being spring in New York and I had to
be a junior in high school and me and
Dei Cano sitting in the cemetery with no
shirts on doing coke and drinking a pack
of
nips in the daytime in the
daytime like [__] 3:30 the afternoon
I still remember that plane this in that
same Cemetery yeah because we learned
that that Cemetery took a half hour off
your travel
time it really did 30 to 40 minutes off
your travel time yeah you cut from 68th
Street and you came out on 41st Street
was it something like that everyone in
the town all the kids like taught each
other like that you learn from like
maybe the third graders or you just
found it out yourself like cuz I had
stuff like that like the your older
grades would tell the younger grades
about it or were you just I mean I can't
even imagine walking through a cemetery
if you ever go to Jersey it's a 34
three what's the [__] math equation
here Steve burn you a little high and
[__] if you have three quarters or
something what's left a quarter right so
a quarter of New Jersey is [__]
cemeteries if you been to [__] New
Jersey Cemetery a a quarter of New
Jersey is cemeteries and I'm talking
about huge [__]
cemeteries you know we had we hawk and
Cemetery I mean three blocks from my
house that's where my mother's buried we
hawk and Cemetery is three blocks from
my house it's we hawk and it's not we
hawk New Jersey there are a lot more
cemeteries back East why AR there any
here why are they out here they throw
them in the [__] beach I don't know
they bury them on the 170 I don't
[__] know what they do with these
people they send them back to Mexico who
the [__] knows you fly you fly in a JF K
or lagoria there's always that huge
Cemetery as you're descending you're
like this is not a good this you
shouldn't see it this before you're
Landing it's like do I see need to see a
bunch of tombstones what about that
scene from The Sopranos where they're
doing they have a a funeral and it's
like underneath the the underp the
highway underpass yeah like underneath
like six or seven highway underpasses is
a cemetery I told you that cemeter is
everywhere what are you going to do with
them where would you want to build the
[__] highway on a cemetery nobody's
going to complain if they build a over a
[__] neighborhood people going to say
what the [__] cars are doing 150 past my
house all [__] day a cemetery nobody
gives I'm telling you New Jersey is a
quarter of that state is cemeteries I
don't know why then you take it like out
of New York City New York State like
skincity and all those places allany
they're Rec c a [__] Cemetery too and
I guarantee Boston is's no [__] party
either oh it's but did you guys ever
stop when you were driving around the
Northeast and just go to those
cemeteries when I went to that wedding a
couple years ago I went to a cemetery in
Vermont they had it was like you were
talking about they had like
1,600 headstones It's So Co explain
something to like where do you get
buried if you die in Arizona do they
have cemeteries
in cuz it's a desert clim do are they
maybe they have those uh like the where
you get stack yeah yeah those freak me
out though I don't want to I'm sure that
they dig in the desert but I I would
think that the soil's harder I I have no
idea what the [__] I'm talking
about I don't know where you get buried
in Arizona that's my point why you
planning on dying in Arizona people
usually live in D in La you want to go
to Arizona [__] yeah I'll die doing the
temp improv that be my Swan Spirit of
Danny M comes and get
you that that's
uh it's funny that we share the uh
office here with the funeral people come
on well yeah from across funeral across
the street this not this not our office
but this building this building they
came during the day it's morbid I grew
up with a kid who had a funeral B Steve
bur he was like you have no idea yeah
and he was cool as [__] I started
hanging out with him when I was about 15
yeah you know his parents had money so
they leave him they'd leave for three
months at a time and this [__]
would have to do the little menial task
you know picking up bodies dropping them
off oh God how old is he now he's my age
now he's a big shot but I mean and he
still has the funeral PA it's doing
busier than ever yeah but in those days
I hung out with him and there was a lot
of nights he'd say what are you doing T
can you put a suit on I need an usher
you know and I'd have to you have to
keep the sinks clean and you have to
take the garbage out and you have to you
know [__] and I me it was crazy on
the other side we also had big time
parties there you have no [__] idea
at a funeral home oh my God late nights
after we'd be at a bar 3: in the morning
nobody what do you want to do was take
them back to the funeral Paul I
can't what the [__] you talking about
you can't you follow is in Florida come
on that's a tough sell to a girl right
oh please they love it when you oh you
show them the caskets and [__] I know
for a fact this guy banged maybe eight
chicks and caskets oh God that's [__]
casket chicks love that [__] dog they
get banged in a
casket oh my God you find the girl with
the Marilyn Mansion t-shirt you're like
hey get over here I think I know you on
party tonight do you close the top or I
I never asked that's freaky if they
close the top no I don't think you could
breathe you Clos the [__] top right
do you like do you like uh-huh okay oh
my God we used that was
our from from the age of like maybe 18
to 20 that was my
headquarters what his funeral parlor cuz
I was there was a par next to it called
Luchi and Luchi were where was where it
went down nothing my friend hated more
than that bar next to it Luchi yeah
because all his custom you know this kid
always thought he was hired everybody
and here's his neighborhood bar Luchi
they're throwing dots they doing blow
they're having fist fights in there you
so it was convenient because if you're
in a funeral parlor you go there do a
blast and get a cocktail then come back
to the funeral like nothing happen this
was crazy [__] Jesus this is crazy [__]
but I still remember him and I were
going to see Michael Jackson at the
metal ANS for the victory
tour and he goes dog I'm going to bind
you we got to take a ride to Kennedy to
pick up a body that's coming from
Florida good God I said I'll do it on
one condition we stop in Harlem get a
couple bags of wheat done we get in the
[__] car we shoot over the we get the
reefer we go to JFK get the body drive
back I'll never forget this we [__]
pull in and what you do is those uh
those uh those things that they come the
body
on it's usually a oneman thing those
gurns cuz all you got to do is pull it
and the legs pop up and this as he comes
out the bottom legs pop up so all you
have to do is just so I ran out of the
car cuz I had to call a girl I'll never
forget this and I went into the EMB
bombing room and there was a phone there
I mean this is how natural it was yeah I
went into the EMB bombing room I picked
up the phone and I called this girl and
I'm like we'll pick you up at like 6:30
blah blah blah and I'll never forget
that I look over and he's like die and
he threw the body at me what and the
body was on the thing like like running
on the wheels [__] I moved out of the
way and it hit the wall and all sudden
the mouth went and I [__] dropped
steeve bird who had more fun than me
growing up steeve bird what the [__]
hangs out with a stiff [__] Wrangler
was there I mean did he ever think that
there were like were there haunted
spells or were there like kind of
ghostly Spirit or entities that ever
happen at the funeral home or not one
time not once he was one he's still one
of my best friends I mean now he's just
really busy and you know I mean I I took
him to the long as you're out Premiere I
mean that's how tght I am with I he's my
brother you know yeah uh but that was
and but then this is where it used to
get funny we used to get [__] up we
used to get [__] up this was dead
people in the basement still this is oh
yeah we used to get [__] but no no
this was way before I mean we used to
have a blast with him growing up he was
really a fun guy because if his pag went
off that mean he had to pick up a body
he would have like three pages and one
page in particularly went off but once
he had a couple in them we just take the
pager from them you know what I'm saying
like once you have a couple [__]
cocktails com he we take the pag from
then we get home and his dad would be
waiting for him where the [__] you been
there's two bodies in new airport you're
out [__] dilly d and get the [__]
car and we' be gacked [__] up out of
our minds and he told me you got to take
the ride with me are you [__] kidding
me you stole the Beeper so three of us
would have to get in the car and take a
ride out pick up bodies because we were
going to drop the bodies off and go get
another package I mean that's how crazy
we were at that age but there was a lot
of nights where we would still be up at
8 and he'd have a
funeral oh God okay so he'd drop us off
and we getting whatever car we had and
we wait 10 minutes and we go by the
funeral parl and he'd have the cones in
front of the funeral par he'd be
standing there with his suit pale oh
yeah you know his jaw would still be
gone and my friend would step on the
[__] gas and knock over his car
hilarious
[Laughter]
hilarious what is it like being high in
a car and you can hear like the like
just the body rattling around and
whatever thing it's in like that metal
one night me and him got [__] lit and
we came and went through Hudson County
Park to get to the George Washington
Bridge and it was the beginning of a
snowstorm and the car started spinning
around
Jesus we got to [__] stiff in the car
get him I mean these these were just
times that I wish there was so many
times I wish I had a video camera like
it would have been unacceptable but
these are the things that people are
never believe like us pulling over in
Harlem with a [__] stiff in a car and
getting a bag of reefer getting a
package I mean this is crazy like he
wasn't even back there yeah like it was
just a part of doing business like if
you wanted to run into the city I'd take
the ride me to pick up the body I'll
stop [__] and I can't imagine like
parting with my friend and me like all
right we got to go pick up a dead body
and then we'll come to be continued i i
a dead body would be the end of my night
but it's kind of like you know it's like
all right let's there was so many
different when I was in high school
there was a kid named Rob Merlo his dad
had a restaurant
called robertto or something and it was
the second best like like it was written
up like in New York area's Best uh and
he used to cut a deal with us man he
used to said listen guys plain and
simple Friday night you come you clean
the
bar or you can eat whatever you want boo
so basically if we went to his
restaurant at 12 we take an
eightball and just drink all night for
free after the bar closed oh wow and
drink till 6:00 and then take the car
down the shore that's how crazy we were
in high school we had all these little
scams that we could do what are you
going to do Friday night deep BR I'm why
come with us we get over there about
2:00 we would go to Joe marries a 10
drink till 3: and then take the car to
[__] mandoos mandoos that was the
name of it and we have to clean but we
cleaned [__] lit when you're 19 or 20
you don't give a [__] because we knew at
7: we were just going to wash our hands
and go down the shore for the weekend
yeah can you imagine that and not even
going to sleep that's crazy not even
thinking about going to sleep till yeah
maybe Sunday you couldn't have done a
good job cleaning and then like he P you
you cleaned and you took all his booze
he must have been pissed he didn't give
a [__] it was his father's restaurant he
was there with us no but the father must
have been pissed he didn't know the
father was somewhere the father owned
elevator companies this was just like
his [__] right off and the restaurant
became like this [__] big deal right
ups every time you were in there the
Knicks were there anybody you know all
those athletes that lived in New Jersey
were there you know so it was kind of
interesting to go in there you know what
all that [__] is yeah you were there for
eight years the reason why I wanted to
talk to you him I shot a special in
Vegas and it just failed miserably give
me a to z how many specials have you
done I just finished my fourth fourth
give me the anatomy of the Steve Burn
special the anatomy how long to take to
write for me two years because special
so you've done four specials in eight
years yeah uh well because of Sullivan
and Son it took me an extra year and a
half for the third one so yeah yeah
about like almost you know eight or n
was it stressful for you did you go into
it with a different
mentality yeah I think the first one you
know the first one is a culmination of
oh okay thanks uh is a culmination of
your first few years in standup so you
have all these years and you're trying
to figure things out and it's just a
jumbled mess and then my second and
third one I started figuring out but
basically what it comes down to is for
me at least you come up with a thesis
what is what is it I want to communicate
what is the question that I would like
to answer over the course of this hour
special so for example the second one
was burn identity and it started with me
going to China for the Olympics and
everybody there is like what are you
it's like oh I'm American but then you
come back to America and people are like
oh what are you it's like oh I'm Korean
and Irish and I just thought if I'm
American in China and if I'm American in
Europe or Ireland but in America I'm not
American I'm Korean and Irish that would
be a fun way to explore my identity
being Korean and Irish and so that that
became the th for that of saying I'm an
American this I'm going to prove it this
that the other thing make fun of a bunch
of different races and then this one I
turned 40 I have two kids now and I
didn't want to just have somebody turn
on Netflix for example and see oh this
guy's 40 years old and he's talking
about being 40 well I'm [__] 21 I'm
in college [__] this guy I'm I'm going
to watch you know Aziz or jezel Nick or
somebody
else so I thought why not try to
communicate to somebody half my age and
give them lessons along with my children
so you know you tell the truth you don't
lie where's the joke in that where's
something that's happened to me that's a
personal experience that I can parlay
that to somebody half my age so that
kind of became the backbone of this new
hour do you ever write jokes that you
know won't be on the special or are all
of your jokes now no yeah I mean you
write them all thinking okay this will
be a part of it and I actually had a
closer that was really like really you
know it got Applause breaks all the time
was fail proof it was just just great
and I closed on it and it was until the
last month that I thought you know you
built up all this Goodwill you talk
about your family your daughter your son
your wife and family and then I'm doing
this dirty sex joke about the analogy
between women buying shoes and guys
thinking that same way with [__] and
it it was great and then I just thought
do I want to end the show like this
after talking about my family this whole
time so I just thought I'm going to
scrap it and do something a little more
meaningful so I wrote something about a
month ago and that became the closing
bit so but I I think everything that
I've written will possibly end up on the
on the special yeah that's crazy that
you said that cuz Joey you had a bit in
this where you said a word a couple
times but you said it by mistake earlier
and you said I can't say it there
because it's too much and like I can't
imag I would never have thought that you
would have to think oh I've built up all
this Goodwill I don't want to have a
dirty like for and for you like Joey
like you're a dirty comic you would
think well
you say stuff like that so you would you
would think you would say it as much
time as many times as you wanted but
it's interesting that you have to Center
yourself a little bit well I think just
in terms of this particular CU my last
one I was really dirty at the end the
last like 15 minutes it's just like a
Fourth of July Statue liberty fireworks
finale I had the whole crowd chanting
anal you know it's like you got a
thousand people going ano ano to this
poor girl in front who has not received
anal I'm telling her honey it's coming
like a full moon embrace yourself
there's a freight train out there
circling this country heading right
towards that [__] so it just you know
it's like I did that last one it was so
dirty and then this one I'm talking
about my kids I'm talking about my wife
I'm talking about my family I'm talking
about my kids and yeah then the the last
joke just wouldn't fit because it's not
how you start it's how you finish
especially with these specials you
remember Chris Rock dropping the mic you
remember that last joke and it's like I
want this special to be remember
Remembered in a in a different light
than than the other
way and let's say that was your first
special would you have made that choice
or would you have just gone with a good
joke oh I would have gone with a good
joke yeah in a heartbeat yeah but I
think the older I've gotten it's like
especially with kids now with my kid
it's like I I always want them to be
proud of me and and like I've got some
really dirty jokes I mean I remember my
first Comedy Central half hour I'm on
all four is doing a doggy style joke
talking about how women just lose the
wheel within 4 minutes and they just
drop down and ass STS popped up but the
heads just bang so it's banging on the
stage and I'm talking oh my God your
pillow smells like [__] and now here I
am banging my stage my ass is on the air
and I look in this crowd and my mom and
dad are both looking at me and I'm just
like oh for [__] sake but it you know
at the time you're going to do the joke
it it kills and it still did I I I love
that joke my daughter was sitting on my
lap yesterday I'm watching some on the
computer with we're going through some
videos and I got like this uh chill in
my spine you know
for years I tried to recircuit myself
like try to be a different person and
this little girl is doing it all by
herself like uh cuz you're thinking
about what you have on YouTube and how
in 15 years yeah and and if you want me
to tell you I'm lying to you and I
haven't thought about this uh you don't
know anything about me like I've thought
about this yeah something's going to
happen one day she's going to go on
YouTube for two hours and see some of
this [__] and go what the [__] happened
this is not the guy I knew or I didn't
know my Dad [__] did this or he
mugged the [__] or he did this or he you
know it's just a it's a big worry of
mine it's a very big war of mine I think
it's going to be great no it's not no
it's not because I tell you what man one
of the things I'm very much against is
uh parenting with alcohol or anything
like that I've always felt in my heart
because I grew up with a mom that
[__] drank in front of me she smoked
open in front of me so I got the I have
the ability to say this [__] that when
you see your hero
doing something that's it that's it
there's no alcohol in my [__] house
for a [__] reason there's no [__]
alcohol in my house there's weed on the
balcony for for now today but one she
watches me when I go outside guys yeah
they ain't [__] stupid they smell
something they watch when you go outside
and come back and why you go outside and
sometimes She Bangs to see why I'm
outside you know uh if she's not
thinking about doing drugs and she sees
me smoking on one of these
periscopes you know there there went her
hero sming a that's how I look at things
I know a bunch of people going to
disagree with me I know how that's what
it was for me and I made a [__]
analysis of all the kids I grew up with
I have a friend that's crazy Timmy
Holloway listens to the podcast still he
a [__] uh Teamster and he one thing
about his F his parents his parents knew
we were doing everything but they would
say in this house you're not going to
have a [__] beer yeah I respected
that oh my God this his grandmother
would squash the beers with her hand the
bud wise crush them on her head Crush no
she crush him with her hand it was
hilarious but in their house you were
not allowed to drink yeah until this day
I really respected that even me and I
you know 1982 I was doing blow pills
heroin I respected that you weren't
allowed to drink so these are the things
I'm scared of yes if and I know that you
don't want to see your daughter's
talking about doggy style Jesus [__]
Christ the [__] I got on eating ass
sticking fingers in your [__] and
picking him up by the hoof you know I'm
going to need my daughter to see that
[__] and that's a reality that you know
we deal with later but for right now
from here on in I'm going to make a
conscious decision to
maybe
watch yeah you try to cuz even like in
the special I just filmed you know I had
this joke about you know this girl in a
porn and how she deserves love and here
I am I'm acting it all out the girl's
getting from behind she's jerking off
guys blowing guys and at the end I go oh
my God this is being filmed and I feel
like years from now my daughter will be
at a lunch table in junior high school
with a bunch of her friends around a
tablet and there'll just be me a gif of
me just like doing all this [__] and
girls are like what's your dad doing oh
my dad he's getting butt [__] and he's
blowing guides and jerking them off but
he's working he's at work it's like oh
okay good that's what I have there out
there out there in the world but I'm I'm
addressing it as opposed to like the
last special that's on on Netflix now
was so racial but I I was doing it just
before my daughter was born and I mean I
I think I went there and I I crossed the
line at certain points too but that
that's something that also resonated
with me because as as my daughter gets
older I don't want her you know cuz
everybody can skew it however the way
they want it to because as a comic when
I talk about race it's like it's like
where when I grew up in Jersey I grew up
in Pittsburgh especially in New York
City that's why I filmed the special in
New York City the last one Champion it's
because you can talk about about race
freely in New York City because people
don't give a [__] they're just like oh
it's a black guy yeah I don't give a
[__] whereas in Iowa it's like oh my God
it's a black guy don't you got to watch
what you it's like no in New York
anybody can make fun of anybody cuz
you're all jammed in that 14 square mile
island and everybody's there just
busting balls cutting chops and knowing
that that city is everybody's got each
other's back at the end of the day New
York City I believe the time I spent
there so I think when you talk about
race these days it's so so thin ice and
I don't want my daughter grow getting
older and any of her friends thinking oh
this guy oh her dad's racist or whatever
it just completely the opposite cuz I
always thought that when you make fun of
people you make fun of the ones you love
and I always thought you can make fun of
anybody here young I'm sorry goalie oh I
was just going to say ex I I totally
agree that I think the problem that a
lot of parents have are that they that
you just think it's [__] especially
now with the internet I didn't really
grow up with the internet but now even
younger kids must know that weed's okay
or something or D like Dar is kind of
[__] or stuff like that but it's
it's always it's always the parents who
like have like honest conversations that
the kids turn out the best so now it'll
be embarrassing for them when they're
young but every kid is embarrassed of
their parents in Middle School like like
you guys are going to be the cool
[__] dads it's going to be
embarrassing from like 8 to 16 or
something but after that you're I think
especially like Joey you know with
everything he's done and just being so
such an open honest book I think it's
just like as a dad and especially as a
comic you know just from me speaking
it's just like we've seen everything
like we there's no party you're going to
go to that's better than any party we've
been to there's no body you're going to
hang out with that's cooler than anybody
we hung out with so whatever it is
you're doing as a kid it's like go Ahad
and do it have fun but listen to me I've
seen it all so really take this in and I
I that's something I want permeated in
my daughter's head it's like listen to
me I'm telling you this it's up to you
to make your own decisions but trust me
I'm a [__] Pro I did it I seen it
I've been around it there's nothing
you're going to do that's [__] cooler
than anything I [__] did so you got
to catch up to me but you're learning
from a pro so just chill the [__] out
know that this is bad but it's up to you
now the baby's a boy the baby's a boy
the girl is three and a now here's the
funny thing now your daughter's 17 your
son's 14 mhm here's your son with three
of his little goomas watching you eating
the girls ass on stage and
talking high five the son but the
daughter like now the boys are going to
be in the room going oh [__] your dad's
the [__] yeah your dad was the [__]
where your daughter's going to be you're
so gross Dad how you know what I'm
saying like that's the but they're
supposed to but at least you're not a
[__] accountant which is great but
you guys are you guys are going to be on
TV you like they're like you're like
eventually they're going to be where are
the stars of Dad can you out like just
to you you guys are going to be but it's
we live in California it's going to be
legal by then oh my God it's going to be
good but you're you're going to be
forced to just be straight up honest
there's going to be no at a certain
point there's going to be no more sugar
Co coating
stuff kids [__] know and they get
insulted when you [__] them they do
yeah I know a lot of kids that are
[__] mad at their parents for
something I grew up with like three
dudes that over the years I was like
what the [__] are you talking about you
know what's funny I think kids honestly
are like any standup audience they cut
through the [__] they know when
you're lying you got to be up front
other than I mean when you're on stage
you got to be funny but there is a
similarity I I believe with children in
the audience they just know you they
they can sniff you out in a heartbeat so
you got to be honest I I think at least
as a comic on stage and as a parent you
always have to be honest you really
believe that you went to the coolest
parties and [__] I think so yeah yeah I
mean I [__] when you were a comic or
before you were a comic oh when I was a
comic yeah I worked I did Beer's mad
house with Bill bur Robert Kelly Dove
David off all these guys out of New York
and beer used to have these shows in
Vegas at the Hard Rock so the show would
be on Saturday you know he'd give you
room so you get in Wednesday and just
part of the whole week so when I first
moved here that's how I paid my rent I
lived in Vegas at the Hard Rock pretty
much for two summers straight and into
the spring and just collected that check
and we saw so it was a blast it was the
[__] best I was young I was single I
was in my 20s I or early 30s and just in
Vegas this was 10 years ago yeah late
20s actually yeah it was the
best and then coming here and just
hanging out with all those guys when I
first moved here to LA and then
obviously in New York City being a
standup in New York City my first seven
or eight years at the comedy cell you're
going out every night I mean I wouldn't
get home until 600 or 7 in the morning
it was the [__] it was the greatest
the absolute [__] what would you do till
7 in the [__] morning a drink hang
out try to meet girls girls at the show
where would you leave the what times
they clo time you know New York you can
seller at that time it was always
Godfree Lampanelli me Arty Fuqua we had
the last four sets from 1:00 to 2: in
the morning so we always closed it out
and if you're there you know it's in
summer New York City nyu's right there
all those college kids I'm just a few
years older than them they want to go
out there [__] yeah tourist is in town
they've never been to the C they just
saw sh Dave Chappelle now they see me on
the same stage and it's like hey I'm
asking you to get it yeah that's kind of
cool so it's like we had a [__] great
run a [__] great run seven in the
morning seven in the morning yeah always
at the Waverly Diner Godfrey and I would
get some Flapjacks and call it a
night that's the best
I always wanted to live in New York I'm
I'm I'm happy with what I'm doing but
that's when I when I interned out here
and I was going back to do my last
semester in college I thought I was
going to go to New York just seemed so
that's such a diff listen night lurking
is a complete different world and there
was no better night lurker than I was
now I'm scared to go out at night like
after like 11:30 I got to go home do bad
[__] happens yeah but I used to lurk I
loved it that's why I want to know what
you I mean I did drugs to in the morning
yeah you know I watched vinyl last night
and and uh you know Dice Clay plays this
guy and and he they give him a big coke
rock at the B party Len the phone rings
three days later he goes dog was still
up that was me and my friends yeah
you're still up at a hotel room you know
still up three guys 11,000 people have
been through there women you [__]
women in there they've left one came
back back and blew your friend you know
she brought nobody's jealous what about
the club he was walking into he was walk
and like there were girls blowing guys
in the bathroom this is Correa when when
I left New York City for me the day I
got in that
car it wasn't like I cried or nothing
but I knew I was missing a great part of
New York City I left New York City
before it ended like the I left first
time in April of 83 and then I came back
and I caught that
85 884 vibish which was still just
superb you know where I understood what
you're saying yeah but I wasn't doing no
[__] comedy track I was working and
you know you you leave your house you in
those days you would go out at 10:30
because Miami Vice came on at 9:00 and
between Miami 9 and 10 you got a package
of Coke liing to your house you did a
couple lines and at 10:30 you walk into
the club with your new shoes and [__]
but you didn't go to a club club you
went to like a New Jersey Club right
with all your [__] little idiot
friends dominicos dominicos we've been
going there since we know the [__]
bartender we get the hook
up you go in there you got a tab is it
just a bar just a bar maybe some food
it's a thousand bread ear but you're not
going to eat you're not going to eat not
eating there you're doing packages and
also like at 2:30 You' shoot into
Manhattan and we go to one of those
[__] crazy clubs yeah now let me see
I'll tell you what was crazy on Thursday
nights I went my friend Mike asle to
Studio 54 one time this was 1984 so all
that lies Manelli [__] was done this was
it was a different Club but I do
remember snort and Coke in the girls
bathroom and it was [__] huge [__]
like that and people [__] the
bathroom guys getting their dick sucked
I wasn't getting my dick sucked I can
tell you I got my I didn't get my dick
sucked
but where the [__] uh where the [__] did
I go that people getting their dick
sucked and stuff like that uh the
graveyard when you took a
[__] the 1040 Club the 1040 Club but I
but that was with kids like when I was
16 that took me to a [__] hooker
house no not the 1041 what's the one
where the guy it's three floors I was
thinking about you I thought that's what
we not Ram R was the gay bar but then
there was that other place but there was
uh it was just a different New York is
very free like I remember walking into
and the names the BL but people had
eight-balls on the table I could have
been a cop yeah the door man just said
hey clean your nose yeah it was [__]
crazy it was just a crazier time and you
see people on Monday I remember my
friend's mom's calling me in 19 1987 my
friend Anthony satino I get a call from
his mom once a month coko you talk to
Anthony he was on a plane to Vegas I was
hoping he's by you you know because
those people in New York would get two
three days of coke on them and go what
do you want to do we going to sit in the
hotel room [__] let's go to Miami you
know how many times my friends showed up
in Colorado in those days Jesus like one
time they showed up I was in Boulder and
I got a call I show up some place and I
this is a [__] this is a tremendous
story I get to my house and they're like
hey your friends are here what are you
talking about they just called they're
at the airport call them at this number
I go all the way 45 minute drive to the
airport sure enough they paid the guy to
tell me not they're at the strip club in
Denver I sent them I put them in a car I
get to the strip club they got the whole
table they're [__] whacked foam's
coming out of their noses were up in
Jersey and we like let's go to Denver to
see let to Denver we went to uh we went
to the really good strip club they
rented a hotel across the street like
four [__] rooms connected Jesus then
we went back up there and they bought
champagne and we're up there drinking
and three strippers came up then two of
them got paranoid and gave me the Coke
and we hit it in the wall and the tissue
thing where the tissues come out of the
wall I never forget that and they forgot
which one it was and then we got up the
next morning they were straight they're
like we're going back home you could
keep the Coke I'm like you got to be
[__] kidding me we paid for the room
till Friday but we're going
back where did they get this money they
were selling
Coke and they would go on these
binges and they would [__] go for
three or four goddamn
days they would so they were trying to
make money but they were doing that much
of it [__] but they're good friends cuz
they go they're doing blow and they go
we got to go see Joey oh my God we got
to go see him now go to nework and then
they just [__] show up that's the
best listen the 80s people showed up
with no suitcases yeah do you understand
M you know what it's like if I just call
you go Steve Burn Co was going on
nothing Joey what's up where are you
LAX what are you talking about I'm an
LAX I'm going to take an Uber listen I
got two ooun of coke on me call your
friends it's the best it's from Nora
it's left over and you like okay and I'd
show up and and with this cloth yeah
like three days all I did was get up
take a shower and put this clothes back
on yeah snort coke you know smoke and
Airline [__] piss and I'd buy clothes
tomorrow but tonight we party with the
two that's how [__] crazy they and I
say where were you guys well we went
from Philly to Atlantic City to [__]
uh Connecticut and then we flew out here
so how long you guys been gone since
Saturday it's [__]
Thursday have you guys slept we slept on
the plane for an hour this [__] flush
the coke down the toilet thank God we
got another shipment sent out to the
whole time it was craziness and I'm
sitting there going oh my God this could
have been
me now I get why you don't want to go to
like the Hollywood parties like it just
like who go like if Mercy ever wanted to
go to like a Hollywood party one day be
like listen my friends flew out with no
suitcases for a week I've never been to
a Hollywood party when I got here I
think I went to one one night to meet
somebody and I walked in and there was a
dude dancing with the wall and I'm like
I don't need this in my life and people
were sitting there going like look at
him he's brilliant and he was an actor
I'm not going to mention no names no
names he was dancing with the wall and
people were like oh my God he's gone now
I haven't seen him in a movie in 15
years that was like a that was like a
[__] up movie he was in or something I
forget what the kid's name was anyway
and that was it that was my history of
Hollywood parties yeah they just weren't
I
didn't el padre is as crazy as I
get you ever go to help comp that's so
yeah you see some crazy [__] in there
every night when I go to the store I go
tonight I'm going to go over there and
get a burrito I went about 3 weeks ago
but they got valet parking now [__] you
I used to run this back parking lot you
know what I'm saying I used to be out
here till 6:00 in the morning cuz that
used to be a happy when I first moved to
LA that was a happening comedy
neighborhood it was Stan hope depalo
Mitch Hedberg Josh Wolf Ralphie May
everybody lived on those blocks and they
would meet and play tennis and it was
craziness this is
97 but now they went Valet Park and El
pad they can suck my
dick [__] painful how about Jumbo's
Clown Room you do that never never never
that I thought you would be a ringer for
that that's it's such a it's such a dive
[__] hole but it's so fun and it's great
and it's all these girls are tatted up
like suicide girls and you know they're
they're not the hottest but they're
really nice and it's just just like a
fun VI are they naked uh I think they
get shirtless but every time I've been
there I've been just Fu I've heard about
that place that's I heard about that
place when I first moved here do they do
comedy that LE all all I heard is it's
kind of like a weird kind of a strip
club Weir weird strip club it's a really
really weird strip club but there's no
it's called Jumbo's Clown Room but
there's no clowns right it's just it's I
don't know why it's called that but it's
really [__] and every time I've been
there I've been so drunk whoever I go
with I buy T-shirts for everybody it's
like we got to remember this stucking
night it sounds kind of like che where
Ari films the show cheetah it's it's on
uh Hollywood Boulevard past Western
towards in between West funny cuz
anytime I wear my shirt that's when guys
you'll be out or like when I wore it on
like the Sullivan Sunset it was always
the crew guys or I was like dude I
[__] love that place it's like that's
it it like brings the guys out of the
woodwork that that have ended up there
and had a great night I've never really
been a big strip club guy I just went
back after maybe 16 years MH I I got off
the exit one night went to this one up
here by myself about a month ago
tremendous yeah I got one table dancing
left that's soda she gave me a table
dance I came in my pants I got in my
car I told my wife a couple days later
she was giggling her ass so yeah I can't
I can't do it I was never really a big
uh let's go down and hang out I get
nervous yeah I get I get really insecure
I get nervous I I give myself excuses
not to be there I think they're going to
hate you I think the strippers must just
hate everyone who walks and I know they
make money off of you but they don't
hate you they half a whes you know they
you got to have something in you to
dabble in that [__] world I think too
when you tell them you're a comic it's
almost like Kindred Spirits right we are
Kindred Spirits yeah cuz this girl said
to me because I just saw you at the
store Wednesday night how [__] crazy
it was great it was [__] great in
fact I walked in and walked out yeah got
in my car and she ran through the door
and she's like come in I just saw you at
the store Wednesday night what are you
doing we started talking great I go what
are you charge I went up looked at the
menu I went to the ATM and I gave it to
her I said do your thing it was great
and it was great it wasn't like I was
there out of desperation right when I
got divorced in 91 I I went to the bus
stop a couple times and I met a girl one
night at Denny's and nothing really
happened we were going to do stuff and
then she went we were going to go on a
date and the chick I was divorcing this
stripper went to get a haircut on the
hill where my wife cut hair MH and sat
in the chair and my wife's like why you
need a haircut and she goes I'm going to
date with a comedian till I joke can you
believe that all the [__] places to
put yourself in God for your guys' first
date she was going to go I was going to
take it to dinner she was going to go
see me host at the
broker so she canceled the date [__]
yeah my wife threw her out of the
chair canel the date canceled the
wedding the marriage it was [__]
crazy this guys
Jesus you know what man I threw we threw
a [__] wrench here the
special what the [__] so the last
special you shot in Chicago not Zanies
not zies no two weeks ago did it and we
were talking about this before the show
CU I think sometimes when Comics film an
hour they film it in front of you know
the Chicago Theater it's like 33500
people or like somebody will go to an
arena and I don't think you hear laughs
you hear you hear like noise and I
thought you watch Sarah Silverman like
she always does it kind of in an
intimate space and I thought I'm going
to do that I'm going to find something
that's not too small cuz hers are like
75 100 people but this was a few hundred
people and we did it at this place
called lincol Hall in Chicago it's
[__] awesome really really great how
many people I think uh 3 400 people
that's all you need Steve bur I got to
do a showcase next Wednesday she Steve
bur yeah I'm having a big problem with
this it's at the cony stor
main oh you you thinking to film it
there no no I got to do a showcase next
weekend for a couple different people oh
I got you and the people who set it up
said let's do the main room I didn't
realize until I went to a store the
other night ago yeah I went to a
Showcase in the main room go the O
that's what I'm saying with a belly yeah
yeah I'm going to cancel it for next
Wednesday tell them to see you in they o
are first of all they they won't move it
for you listen when I moved LA and you
signed with an
agency once a year you would get a call
in like October mhm and your agent would
put me Steve Burn you
know Sebastian yeah Bobby Lee at The
Improv and your agency gave out pieces
of paper with your name and your picture
and what you did and what you want to do
and you went up and they said it was 20
minutes 15 minutes these guys want me to
do an hour an hour in the main room yeah
and I'm like I don't want to do an hour
hour do an hour on the belly you'll
you'll pack it in it'll be crammed it's
just what you want and have them see you
there Adam do that for you on a
heartbeat I think I'm going to move it
to the main room you want to do that on
like a Saturday that's you know but not
even if you filled it up right cuz you
you've been back for a couple of years
you've only done the main room like when
I've been there two three times oh I ate
death in there again last night just to
confirm it I'm an old guy you know what
I'm saying I'm I'm an guy and and you
are what the [__] you are and every once
in a while just so you don't get put in
a monkey wrench you say [__] it I'll do
the main room on a Sunday or a Monday
talk night whatever the [__] it is and
you go in there and you're okay and but
if you've been training in the original
room your timing is kind of off
especially the guy you know what I'm
saying like yeah unless you're like a
slow Storyteller with a suit on B the
the [__] main room works I'm a animal
you know I got no
class but I know this going in Steve bur
the original room is where you go and
you got no class somewhere along the
line you
f the original room is the master of no
class because you'll see it and that's
what turns to the original room is a
magical room you and I you could go home
at it's amazing like especially when you
go on a Wednesday night and there's a
buck 20 in there and you have a mediocre
set but the two jokes you were writing
work how you you I can't wait to get go
back Thursday it's it's it's the
greatest it's and it's and it's $15 yeah
but you want to go back Thursday yeah
like you could do a thousand things you
could work at Walmart and make more
[__] money than 50 it's it's such a
[__] when I get home sometimes from
The Comedy Store and I'm sitting there
sometimes like I watch Sons of Anarchy
to calm down I'm like this ain't dick
that your cool down this ain't dick I'm
[__] crazier than this [__] guys
riding motorcycles we just at The Comedy
Store original room nothing better than
the O cuz the O it's the one like no
matter what you say no matter what kind
of it doesn't matter how far you go how
what you are accepted warts and all in
the o period amongst that crowd in that
room it's the best and when your
timing's in there oh my God it's it's
when you're timing yeah into that room
you know the way the AC you know uh Zay
is the other one by the
airport and he's downtown I love it but
it brings me back to prison you know
what I'm saying I'm doing a prison show
and Sh it's too for some reason my
timing don't work in there you know I'll
tell you this this might sound weird but
you know when I had that show on the air
Sullivan and Son it was so fun doing it
but the few times I've ever felt like a
superstar it was on a Tuesday night in
the O after killer set and you're just
like [__] that's what that's why I got
into this this you get in your car you
tip doc doubl yeah tip doc doubl go get
yourself a car and dog get the [__] out
of my face I'm out here boom I'm getting
15 but I'm giving you a 50 that's how
that's how good I do let me take my my
time on the way out so I don't hit cork
mowen's motorcycle over but then I'm
going to [__] lay a patch out of here
I did it Victory and you're going to
make a left on Sunset to prove your
point [__] it there ain't no biker cop
it's Tuesday night
[__] it's [__] great really
is it really
oh my God I love Tuesdays and Wednesdays
when you go up there with you got 15
minutes and you go up there with 7
Minutes of material that you have an
eight that you had just been thinking
about that morning yeah and you remember
to write down no it seemed like you
weren't you didn't really want to do an
hour would you rather do like a 15 or 20
minute oh my
God to do an hour in front the industry
oh the worst on a Wednesday
nightly is the worst
you always want to leave and onean thing
more when I go to Chicago or or Steve
Burn goes to Pittsburgh We Do 50 [__]
minutes it's fun after you've been there
two or three times you get uh you get
local references yeah that you or now
you get to know it or you get you know
what I'm saying like I I did this joke
in Buffalo that's my favorite joke that
I written ever it's the dumbest joke in
the world that when you call you know
you trying to fly into Buffalo you call
the Airlines and they're always like
really like they're always like they
like I always love that about Buffalo
and buffalo loves it Buffalo is the only
city when you call American Airlines and
go I want to go to Buffalo like listen
you don't want to go to
Buffalo stupid [__] that they like you
know what I'm saying though yeah it's
stupid [__] but after you've been there
two or three times you get to know
things when you're on like a Thursday
night in there and then Saturday comes
on that's a great feeling you go back to
your hotor you got to check in your
pocket and you just let them [__]
know what the [__] was going on in your
heart even the 7:30 show which I'm %. I
eat de on the 7:30 shows on a Saturday
night I'm the king of those things so I
know it going in yeah so I make like a
be list of all jokes I want to try the
offensive as [__] just to get it out of
the way and I pack them in there like
every six minutes then I pack them in a
little heavier towards the
end
very important that's really good that
you the you're smart when it comes to
the special that's why I wanted to talk
to you about it I failed no I completely
failed
complet how quick I want to unleash it
on you right you know when I come out
there especially at I learned that at
The Comedy Store
listen add to you when you're at The
Comedy Store from Thursday to Sunday
night you got to bring it the first
three [__] minutes especially if mity
was lurking yeah you if mity was lurking
you had three [__] minutes because
that [__] could be having a
conversation in the main room and she
would have this ear zoned into the
original room and she would tell you
yeah you'd walk back there and she'd go
come here how' you do not too good that
stupid junk didn't work God damn it yeah
how'd you know dog it was [__]
crazy so that style that I had to jump
on people was from bombing yeah I bombed
so bad behind Don marera I bombed so bad
for so long behind uh Paul money that I
go this is the only way I could learn to
grab the audience just by grabing them
you know keep it going for Steve Burn
what the [__] is going on with you
[__] I'm not GNA do nothing Steve
Burn you go up there and start Dilly
down after a really good act yeah and
you're just sinking the clock is on
you're sinking you're up there playing
around and all a sudden you loseing on
the 4minute Mark at The Comedy Store
original room on a [__] Wednesday
night or Thursday you're done yeah
there's no and I've done it that's why I
know from experience I've done it
plenty well that I kind of miss cuz you
don't really bring me to the store
anymore cuz like you we've talked about
you've been working I kind like those
are my favorite when you go and it's
like for like eight it seems like 8
minutes it's just you don't stop
laughing I know people get tired but I
would love to see like like how long do
you think you could do a special of of
just that and then just put that out
it's the internet well what you would do
is the way I would do it was open up
like that strong for like seven minutes
bring him back to normal then you got to
go on another rant which is what Bill
Bird does brilliantly right Bill Bird
does is the king of that he does it the
best you've ever seen ever right now at
this point yeah he goes on a [__] six
minute rant calms you down for for four
finger bangs you for three and then
takes you right back to that [__]
place for 8 nine minutes now he pushes a
little more watch his style he's
brilliant at doing it so the first rant
six the second is nine then that third
one he takes you into deep waters you
know I forget the one bit he did on know
you know he just takes you into that 12
minutes then he seems to wrap it
together and he gets the [__] out of
there I got nothing against that that's
a beautiful [__] uh that's a
beautiful
system not system uh say the word from
me Steve bur just the es and flows of
his of his orchestration I guess of of
the duration of time that he's on stage
he really does know how to hit the Beats
he knows how to hit you out of the gates
and then he knows how to close he he's
just I agree with you I think he's the
best he was always a guy when I started
in New York you know if I was a freshman
bill was like a sophomore junior and
then Colin Quinn Norton Voss Patrice
Geraldo those guys were all like the
seniors at the comedy seller but I
always thought Burr was my favorite and
I've told him this many times and he
knows this when we we used to work
dangerfields all the time like man
you're my [__] favorite comic and you
know I'm just a few years younger than
him but I I always looked up to him I
still do I think he's [__] he's just
[__] great he's brilliant and he's a
great guy too why you brought it up I
got to ask you next time I go to New
York should I work danger Fields never
done it 10 people have tweeted me and
said Joey you got to go danger field
Saturday dangerfields you'd kill it
you'd [__] mop them up but I would do
it once just to say you did it cuz we
you know you saw those HBO specials it's
cool it's still rotary phones same
carpet same Green Room same couches same
Furniture a lot of history but uh I I
don't know the sellers the the sellers
no that's the mac daddy and Ma daddies
but but you should do it you you would
kill kill did youed to do it on Tuesday
nights and stuff like that oh God
Tuesday in front of four people how
brutal bombing bombing I mean just
straight up [__] bombing questioning
is this the right move for me should I
do cuz danger Fields the spots are half
hour so you half hour dark room one
light that's it and it's four people two
are on the back making out another two
are just so bomb they're not even
listening and just talk it's it's the
worst of the worst but it makes you it
it it makes Mak you accept failure so
much quicker than any other club I've
ever been in I did 9mon term in New York
City what a lot of people don't know is
I did a 9 Monon bit of comedy in New
York City from uh February from January
of 93 MH to maybe November of 93 I drove
a limo I lived in Fort Lee I took a bus
into the city in the mornings I sold
cars on 11th Avenue I mean and I went to
all those commy spots and New York broke
me as a comic I'm not going to lie to
you guys I could tell you any other
story I took a I took a standup comedy
class there just to reinforce me I used
to do the New York comedy club stand up
New York Jes oh yeah yeah I was like in
death but it was my uh second year of
Comedy yeah I didn't really know what I
was doing and these guys were putting me
up if I showed up with five guys so I
always had my buddies all they needed
was an invite you know all my buddies
needed was somebody to [__] invite
them to a club and they'd show up and
they'd back me and I kept going going
and going and going but there was that
other side that I
didn't in La there were coffee shops
when I first came there in New York
there were these [__]
seedy places and there was one in
particular that broke me St bur yeah y
old triple n oh God yeah I know where
that is open mik started at 12 at
midnight was that still around tell me
that's still there yeah it's still there
yo troin is still around I don't know if
they still do the open m I've done
comedy there and I know exactly what
you're [__] talking about so yeah
that's uh oo that's a that's yeah that
play me like that broke my soul yeah
what is it it's just a shitty Pub it's a
dive kind of bar but um I remember cuz
it was the seller then Boston and then
just a few blocks away is you old triple
in and so the guys that couldn't pass at
the seller decided let's put the show
together and everybody that was in
between spots with would go over there
and it was yeah it was eating death but
I used to go there at 12 and sign
up and your spot would be at like you
know
138 yeah and people would come in and
bump you when I couldn't say nothing
yeah and I was driving a limo and I had
a grandma blow my pocket and I was dying
to do it but I would not do it until I
did my three [__] minutes you
know and it was just so humiliating to
me like I wanted to do comedy so bad
like I was [__] counting on it steep
bur you know and uh I went there one
night and I
died died like I thought I had this
Brilliance you know yeah this [__]
the the guardian angels are back time to
put your B speakers back in the window I
like I just wrote this garbage and I
went up there that was one of the joke
I'm serious that was one of the jokes I
wrote guardian angels are back in New
York time to put your bow speakers back
in the windows you know that got a boo
right they got a [__] quick
Boo and then Something Happened One
Night I went I like I ate
death then I went back and I ate death
again and I'm like I don't know about
this I think I'm just going to sell Coke
MH and then I went back again and like
was was in
there and I go I get it
yeah I get it now yeah and people like
you're not going up he's doing
something and I washed some face 8
minutes it
was okay you know what he was doing
there was eight people in the audience
yeah and he was doing it like there was
300 right and I go okay I get it I got
to move to a different place do comedy
and I'll get to this level yeah once I
saw that that broke me that the behavior
how people treated me at the uh what's
the guy that died leukemia guy over
[__] Lucian whatever that that club
they they just embarrassed the [__] out
of me they yeah they might as well [__]
me in the ass at that age and put a dick
in my mouth it was [__] humiliating
what did they do just just just they
treated you like [__] you know when you
weren't uh if you're not part of the
club oh my God you have no [__] idea
when you went in there they looked at
you like if you were going there to rob
the place you know and you had to sell
tickets on the streets I did it all man
yeah but wasn't myty the same
way it was a different
different you know and it's the level I
was at also nobody talks to nobody when
you suck dick you know nobody talks to
you when you suck ass on stage they talk
to you [__] uh once you start picking
up momentum so by the time I got to the
store I had known people I had done
comedy for a while it was a different
[__] game you know so it all panned
out I been doing comedy 7 years when I
walked into the store when I walked into
the old triple n I'd been doing comedy
18 months yeah and had been on stage 13
times do you know what I'm saying but I
had a business card that's a comedian I
didn't know the [__] game Ste you
know like I told you before man uh I was
watching at that store that night you
were having a great set you brought me
up and I said this [__] there's
three people in the business that there
was two for a long time and then I saw
you that night and I really you sucked
me in and it was like I laughed but I
felt warm inside like I had just watched
Bonanza it was like one of those things
remember when you were a kid and you
watch those good American whol shows
like that was what was watching you you
weren't dirty that night yeah you were
not dirty that night you you know you s
but not dirty you know there's a
difference between going up there going
I I ate her [__] yeah than saying I
got caught in [__] traffic today and
it defends your face and the whole thing
and I'm thinking I'm like Pablo in 90 in
2000 you know in all the years when he
was whacked and stuff those were the I
used to see people leave there crying it
was like they went to Disneyland that's
the best I could describe it and you
have that quality man than you're a bad
[__] appreciate it Joey I know
you got to go my wife my wife was
texting me so I
got you I love you guys thank you so
much you have any dates coming up love
you bud love you love you very I'm going
to ask in this weekend and then I don't
know I'm just taking a little bit of
time off cuz I just filmed that special
it'll be coming out soon and just going
to lay low for a bit and get my get my
gears going but you inspired me tonight
to think I got got to get back to the
store real soon and get back up there
and start writing again so thank you bud
I'll see you down there my all right
thank you very much pod too right oh
sorry you have a podcast to I have a
podcast with Gary Canon called the
gentleman's Dojo so it's just new and
starting once I get the wheels going I'd
love to have you on all right say my
best to Gary can he's a good man bro
love you boys let me give some shout
outs here real quick and we'll get the
[__] out of here Lee I didn't even know
what time it was we're running late Le
Lee you're supposed to be navigating
this [__] I didn't know we had
an out time you want to eat a brownie Le
oh have another store you have another I
got to work tomorrow so I got to be on
the [__] straight
now what does that mean in reality
though in reality it means
uh I can to leave like uh I don't
know in reality means I got to tell me I
BR [__] glasses to let me get some
shout outs here get the [__] out of here
DJ digs ooky spooky
miq tweets Chris
deep Renegades of skunk Connor is God
Pat houses back in town Eddie B and Matt
Bazar you bad [__] this Friday
the South Point 220 I don't know about
224 we might have to change that listen
my friend one of my best friends in life
is having a show this s and the second
show is already [__] sold out I just
want to give him a plug on this cuz I
love him to death my main man felipa
Spar is at no noia theater if you want
to go to the Early Show with the wife oh
you're with me I'm in Vegas that's right
you'll be wiggling your ass I could I
could send the wife you want to send the
wife she'll go I can ask her yeah yeah
she love I her mom doesn't like the
vegan thing but her mom loves Felipe so
you know what Felipe's wife is pregnant
so oh congrats yeah she go down there
send the wife down there tell
grandmother to make a scarf with a get
send like a Saint's eyeball or some [__]
in that [__] thing and put the good
Mala I didn't know that that's really
cool yeah I don't even know if I should
be saying it I think they have a podcast
yeah they have a podcast together and
they said it so it's a beautiful [__]
thing bro how was your week last week
good everything good in your world I had
a great weekend uh you made fun of me
but we went to Inn out I have like how
good was it oh my God I haven't had in
and out forever but it was uh how long
was the line you know we Wen like we we
we kind of messed up we went a little
bit later like 9:00 it still took like
10 minutes probably but uh like it's
it's pretty cool
how like I I even asked her a couple
times I'm like are you sure cuz you said
Stout like why didn't you go to Stout
and not even brought up Stout but she
just loves she's a c she's from here she
just loves in and out and to we had a
great time go over here by the old
office yeah yeah when when they're
really high oh I have a good tip cuz I'm
always afraid that I'm going to lose it
when I'm stoned like I I'll start
giggling and show myself so I started
listening to comedy albums when I'm
driving so that way people don't know
that's how paranoid I
get look at you look at you and [__] but
uh oh and I um for for next year for
people I sent my mom flowers and she's
been talking about it like every day
like it's it's
crazy I've been telling people like for
the last few days I always say have a
good day to people like at stores
because that's when when I worked there
and I started saying ha happy
Valentine's Day and girls just lit up
it's like what you said like making
people's day just saying happy Valentine
Valentine's Day and I sent my mom my mom
flowers and she's been talking about it
for like month so next year guys should
I had a [__] up weekend because I went
to sleep Friday night I got home from
working at 1 oh [__] yeah so I didn't
fall asleep till
3:30 so I got up at 7 with Mercy
you know and I had mercy the whole
morning blah blah blah blah blah blah we
had to run around and then we probably
got home at two with Mercy I took a nap
till like 5: so I didn't even get a
chance to I got to recard that was
it and I felt
bad I should have got us it's still made
up who gives a [__] you know women like
when you make an effort but yeah but you
got
the it was a [__] car with a thing
that spun around yeah but then I spent
[__] tons on on flowers aala and I
was like it was Tiny I can't get cat I
can't get [__] flowers because of the
cats oh I know but that's that's my
point then it's stupid so I mean get
chocolate or something but then we were
going to go out to eat today and then
mercy didn't fall asleep and we took it
to Jiu-Jitsu which was [__]
tremendous when they gave her the ghee
she looked [__] tremendous did they
give her a little belt too yeah she had
the whole [__] thing onuh you know it
was at 3:30 I could take it to there on
Mondays you know she's but but she's
also tired so she wouldn't sit down she
was dancing around like a [__]
ballerina and after 10 minutes I had to
pick her up and she got hotter and [__]
then she started yelling and screaming
then we had to [__] take the ghee off
and take her home then my wife yelled at
me and I yelled at my wife then we
[__] went home and we played with and
everything was back to normal and she
still didn't [__]
nap she doesn't need to nap no man she's
supposed to [__] nap at 1:00 no
that's what I'm saying she's just like
full energy she's [__] got to nap I
stopped napping and it [__] destroyed
me I didn't go back to Napp until I was
25 years old when I dat the stripper she
used to make me take a nap in the
afternoons when I was 30 [__] years
old I never napped in my [__] life I
stopped napping when I was like four I
was running around my mom is a kid I had
no time to [__] nap my dad took naps
my entire life like it was known at my
house like to be quiet yeah because he
sleep work nights yeah you have to take
a nap if you work nights and you work
nights well not really cuz some nights
you not really some nights I work and I
get home at 10:30 that's not working
nights and some nights I get home at
11:30 or 12 you know over the years the
[__] clock is short when I first got
here 15 years ago yeah I walked in the
door at [__] 2 3:00 every
night that's
terrible what about walking in like
Steve Burn 6 o' can you imagine that but
that's New York City you can is that
really just New York you can do
it I can't imagine being out that late
here
in 1985 84 I was staying out a minimum
toe cuz I like the food I like the pizza
over there in the middle of the
night in New York yeah I liked it so I
used to go to different spots and get
two three slices with a soda and take a
meatball hero
home and by the time you get home you
smoke dope in the [__] car and you
smoke another and you eat another
meatball hero I liked all that [__] dog
so I I could see and I did blow till
late night too I don't know it just it's
just been like it's it's been so long
since I stayed up till 6:00 in the
[__] morning how bad is some of that
late night pizza I got some of the worst
in New York at like 5: in the morning
when I was waiting for a bus it was
terrible I knew where to [__] go you
know your friends tell you where to go
different spots and you realize where
they're going now you start going there
you know for me it had to be good and
easy to get there I'm not going all the
way you know what I'm saying like I'm
not going all the way to the Bronx at 2:
in the morning for his life there's got
to be a place in hand and my friends
always found a place for years there was
a good spot over on 15th street by 8th
Avenue by uh the Honda place in
Manhattan that's long gone these places
are long gone Le I don't know nothing
about [__] those cities no more I
don't even know where to [__] get
pizza here I got to go to the [__]
mall like a like a gentile in [__]
some small City I got to even in Los
Angeles I got to go to Joe's Pizza
[__]
whatever yeah that's St bger you can
only eat a Stout Burger once a month
yeah that shit'll [__] kill you it's
delicious but it'll kill they're huge I
love those [__] things but they're
not that big like they're they're not
that big but it's the [__] onion
rings and the french fries with the
cheese that destroy you and the beer you
know who the [__] am I to drink a beer
that one day I was dizzy for four days
you don't like beer I love [__] beer
what you think I drank it for but I Dr I
don't how many times you see me drink a
beer in 5 years maybe two more times
that's it I when the [__] do I drink a
beer I love to drink a beer more often
but I got to drive I got to walk around
I got to do different [__] that night
that afternoon my wife was driving so I
don't give a [__] what's a beer you know
I'm the
co-pilot where's the sheets of paper you
give them back to me [__] it was nice to
have Steve Burn in here he's a [__]
good dude man it very nice he's no no no
no and I'm I was going to get him in
here before the [__] special and uh
you know what man I miscalculated the
[__] the uh the timing so I felt
really bad I wanted to get him in here
to promote the [__] special sometimes
you can't do everything like my man Lee
said
uh I've been using listen me andies and
me been [__] around for like two
years now and I got to tell you
something I wear them before every
workout I wear them before when if I
need a like right now I don't have no
underwear on what the [__] I need
underwear to walk down here I'll be home
in an hour or two why need underwear for
but if I'm flying if I know what the
[__] cracker lacking I got to wear
meundies this is the [__] I've been
wearing I don't wear cotton underwear no
more they creep up my ass they slip so
whether you're wearing a suit or sweats
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your
underwear but instead of making a
statement like Superman's tights under
his everyday clothes your underwear
probably [__] boring right well
listen meundies they're here to change
that
[__] you know why let me tell you why Le
cuz they got a product called modal
every pair Mees is made from sustainable
Source Modell a fabric that's twice as
soft as cotton they all their underwear
bro and they last too that's the other
thing usually when I have cotton [__]
underwear my fat ass stretches out my
nut sack drips these black meundies and
the camouflage ones I got are the older
ones and whenever I put them on those
things are [__] tight that mold doll
is [__] solid you understand me
nothing can describe the FIT and feel of
meundies but once you try them on you'll
understand why they called the world's
most comfortable underwear and if you
don't love the first pair of meundies
they're free no questions asked and if
Uncle Joey likes them I'm telling you I
never liked underwear since [__] 1981
I was like why do you need [__]
underwear for I [__] hate it and if
you I swear to God me and is different
styles and limited edition prints to
help you make a statement with your
underwear right it's a lick your nut
sack and you got your little
me you could save up to $8
20% off your first order when you go to
meundies.com either the subscription or
the single pair that's meundies.com for
20% off your first order meundies.com
Joey yeah meundies.com joeey for 20% off
your first order right so don't mess
with me it's a new year Valentine's Day
you're single you want to spruce up your
[__] go to me on these next year I
guarantee you'll have 10 girlfriends cuz
your underwear will smell good your nut
sack the whole [__] thing trust me
I'm no male model when I slang dick I
slang dick with me undies you
understand who's better than Lisa at
tonight needs to make howar t you want
to eat a brownie too I have three I'm
good with the brownie your three you're
in training this is it this is I'm I'm
fully trained this is Israel week you
got to go deep in [__] [__] let me tell
you what company I keep hearing good and
better things about and I got to get
them to send me more food this [__]
Blue Apron you know why let me tell you
what the menu was for this week chicken
shitel that's what you call it Schnitzel
schnitzel with finger loin potato salad
center cut pork chops with warm beets
that's a two-person plant the family pan
is pink rot with meatballs and creamy
Penta and sweet and sour card with
carrot ginger [__] fried rice who's
better than that you can admit it the
last thing anybody wants to do after
work is go wait online at a grocery
store slep home cook a complicated meal
and it's expensive unhealthy takeout is
even hardly better that's where the new
Service Blue Apron comes in all right
Blue Apron delivers farm fresh
ingredients and a step-by-step recipe to
your home allowing you to create the
healthy handcrafted meal at home without
going to the grocery store dog you walk
out your door and there's a box for less
than 10 bucks per meal Blue Apron sends
your fresh ingredients whether it's the
fish the meat the pork chops perfectly
proportioned making cooking healthy
meals really easy and fun no trips to
the grocery store and no waste from
unused ingredients plus you'll learn to
cook with special ingredients that are
normally hard to find Blue Apron is
perfect for date night cooking with
friends and they even offer family plans
with kidfriendly ingredients so the
whole family could eat well and had fun
preparing meals together each balanced
meal is 500 to 700 calories per serving
and so tasty you'll never know it
cooking takes half an hour shipping is
flexible and free and the menus are
always new they won't send you the same
mail twice they work around your
schedule and dietary preferences and
Blue Apron experts Source only the best
seasonal ingredients for meals like the
one I talked about like the the
Schnitzel or the center cup pork chops
you'll cook incredible meals and be
blown away by the quality and the
freshness all right Blue Apron it's the
better way to cook you get home you got
no drama there's a box you take it out
of the box you put just like they tell
you you read off a card a [__] Momo
can do this you understand me with one
eye this is why this is good you come
home you work hard less than 10 bucks
you do the two family plan whatever the
you want to eat more you're a fat [__]
you want to lose weight this is the way
to do it blue apron.com joeey my treat
really the first two meals are on me
when you go to blueapron.com / Joey
right and as usual my main people on it
I'm back on the shroom Tech [__]
sport I go to Jiu-Jitsu I get home my
[__] gear is drench even the knee
pads now are [__] drench I have to
suck 20 dicks on the street to get my
knee pads that [__] sweaty that and
I'm telling you I'm dropping weight now
I'm feeling healthier I'm moving better
I'm lasting more on the mats today I did
a [__] sweep on a young kid it's
working Le little by little I'm getting
better better and better but the shroom
Tech sport took me the last two [__]
weeks and the immune ever since I
[__] travel you know you got this
[__] new kiwi [__] disease going
around mosquitoes biting your kids born
with [__] up
heads really yeah there's a new [__]
thing going around I don't know name it
but somebody [__] sent me a picture
the other day of these poor kids and
[__] that it's white and pregnant woman
and [__] oh I think I heard about that
yeah what the [__] what do you live in a
in a
closet what the [__] is the picture here
see I don't [__] see it's okay let me
tell you
something this [__] iPhones dog they
don't say they don't say
[__] they [__] uh they [__] lose
my
emails I got to put them on an iCloud I
don't know about the [__] iCloud dog
what the [__] when do they come with all
these by the ways all the [__] son so
they can track you really really why do
I need somebody [__] tracking me you
don't I got got to lock my numbers in I
got to do a thousand things leave me the
[__] alone they're worse than lincol
them people those people when they going
to stop sending me friend request who if
you're on Lincoln then don't bother me
no more every morning I wake up
everybody wants to be my friend on
lincol they're not bothering you
LinkedIn is making them send email I
refuse to give anybody even the
opportunity I'm so pissed off at Link in
them because it's [__] there's
people walking around the streets going
oh I'm part of my business network no
you're not nobody gives a [__] that
you're on there no one gives a f about
yeah but yeah so but they're not
emailing you they'll friend you once but
then LinkedIn will send you requests for
for 18 years until you accept it so yeah
I'm going to I'm thinking about just
getting a flip phone next time what are
you bothering me for anyway why don't
you just get it I'm going to be the sou
Point what you B what what do you work
for appos or something listen I'm listen
this Friday and Saturday I'll be at the
sou Point Casino if you ain't doing
nothing Vegas is the place to be not cuz
I'm jumping up and down you know what
mean I have one drink I [__] PUK
but if you're not doing nothing Friday
and Saturday Le be there eating cake and
[__] next week I'm at the comedy store
and see if we put this together and
don't forget to go see my main man
Felipe spars at the noia theater
Saturday night early show 7:30 all right
I love you [__] see you
Wednesday stay black and beautiful you
sexy [__] and please check out
life of neutral that's right I'm going
to Periscope here in a second so get you
life
together this show is brought to you by
meundies shipping is always free in the
US and Canada and you can save up to $8
a pair with mandi's subscription plan
get the subscription or a single player
get 20% off your first order when you go
to meundies.com joeey that's
meundies.com
joeey show is also brought to you by
Blue
Apron Blue Apron sends Gourmet recipes
and all the fresh ingredients you need
to make them right to your door our
listeners get their first two moves for
free just go to blueapron.com Joey and
start cooking incredible meals at home
with blue apron blueapron.com Joey and
go to on it.com and use cob Church to
get 10% off all the great optimization
products